et si dans ce futur désirable nous
retournions tous sur les bancs de
l'école
imaginez nos établissements scolaires
écoles collèges lycées enseignement
supérieur ouvert à tous quels que soient
notre âge et qu'ils nous permettent de
continuer d'apprendre de développer de
nouvelles compétences et de pouvoir
partager celle ci avec nos concitoyens
qu'ils soient plus jeunes aux plus âgés
imaginez simplement que l'on replace
l'éducation pour tous et tout au long de
la vie au coeur du développement notre
société
je vais vous raconter ce soir l'histoire
du cube le cube est un bâtiment plus tôt
je devrais dire un concept pédagogiques
et éducatifs innovants
situé au coeur de tourcoing tout proche
d'ici
l'histoire a commencé en 2015 avec
l'acquisition d'une ancienne friche
industrielle et textiles a réhabilité
à l'origine de ce concept nous avions
des inquiétudes des questionnements sur
l'évolution de notre système éducatif
dans ce 21e siècle
nous vivons dans une société vu qu'à
peut-être certains parmi vous
connaissent déjà cet acronyme
anglo-saxon il signifie une société
volatiles incertaine
complexe et ambigu
rien que ça
une société où tout évolue très vite
peut-être trop vite en tout cas trop
vite pour notre système éducatif
pôle emploi par exemple nous annonce que
les métiers les plus recherchés
aujourd'hui n'existaient pas il ya
seulement dix ans et que les métiers qui
seront les plus recherchés dans dix ans
n'existe pas encore aujourd'hui
mais
comment fait-on pour préparer
aujourd'hui nos élèves nos jeunes le
mieux possible à des métiers qui
n'existent pas encore
et comment s'assurer que nos
enseignements d'aujourd'hui ne seront
pas obsolète en 2040
comme cette cassette audio
inutilisable
pôle emploi toujours nous annonce que la
durée de vie des compétences techniques
et aujourd'hui de moins de deux ans
alors que dans les années 80 la durée de
vie des compétences techniques étaient
de 30 ans ce qui explique pourquoi bien
souvent on pouvait avoir le même métier
dans la même entreprise pendant presque
toute une carrière
mais aujourd'hui
yat-il encore du sens par exemple a
questionné un collégien lorsqu'ils
arrivent en troisième ou même 1 10 et 1
lorsqu'ils arrivent en terminale le
questionner sur le métier qu'il envisage
de faire plus tard
et quel sens quelle signification aura
encore ce mot métier à l'avenir
un métier c'est un assemblage complexe
de compétences au service d'une mission
un peu comme si un métier était une
bulle
architectes designers concepteurs de
jeux vidéo infographiste médecins
infirmiers enseignants
sauf que là la machine à bulles
s'emballe de plus dans plus de nouvelles
bulles apparaissent alors que d'autres
éclatent et disparaissent tout aussi
vite
comment gardons-nous contrôle
si l'on analyse le contenu de chacune de
ces nouvelles bulles on pourra remarquer
qu'elles ont toutes certaines
compétences en commun ses compétences on
les appelle les softs qu'ils les
compétences transversales
plus simplement si vous préférez les 4 c
créativité communication collaboration
et esprit critique
ce sont ses compétences qui sont déjà
aujourd'hui les plus recherchés dans les
offres d'emploi et par les recruteurs
mais parce que ce sont ses compétences
qui nous permettront de continuer
d'apprendre d'apprendre à apprendre de
développer de nouvelles compétences
techniques et de rebondir d'une bulle à
une autre d'une mission à une autre de
rester employables
avec ces quelques inquiétudes sur
l'évolution de notre système éducatif
nous avions aussi bien heureusement
quelques convictions sur les changements
et apporter la première s'assurer que
les contenus enseignés aujourd'hui ne
sont pas une fin mais un moyen un moyen
de développer le potentiel de chacun un
moyen de développer ces fameuses
compétences transversales ce jeune homme
a visiblement beaucoup de potentiel nous
nous devons de le préserver et de le
développer
ensuite porter un nouveau regard sur la
personne pour transformer le processus
d'apprentissage c'est changer notre
regard sur l'éducation
changer nos références intellectuelles
on dit souvent que le métier
d'enseignant est peut-être le seul dans
lequel on commence avec 20 ans
d'expérience
20 ans acquise en tant qu'élèves et
étudiants mais c'est vous dire
l'inertie qu'il faut vaincre pour
changer ce processus
ne plus se demander comment l'enfant
mais plutôt comment les élèves
apprennent c'est leur permettent de
vivre des expériences de s'ouvrir sur la
société de donner du sens à leur
enseignement et leur permettre au final
de créer leur propre bulle d'inventer
leur propre nouveaux métiers
et au lieu de préparer les élèves pour
l'avenir l'apprentissage deviendra leur
vie nous devons préparer nos élèves à
devenir des concepteurs de problème leur
apprendre à se poser les bonnes
questions poser des problèmes auxquels
ils pourront avec nous participer plutôt
que de se contenter mais comme le et
très bien notre système éducatif se
contenter de poser des problèmes dont
nous connaissons déjà par avance les
solutions
s'il reprend les ingrédients à l'origine
du concept du cube nous avions
l'opportunité de cette friche
industrielle textile à réhabiliter nos
inquiétudes sur l'évolution de ce
système éducatif dans 21e siècle et nos
convictions sur les changements et y
apporter et c'est là qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut se lancer il faut oser qu'il faut
prendre des risques et oser mettre en
oeuvre cette belle citation de peter
drucker et si la meilleure façon de
prédire l'avenir
était de le créer
alors il s'agissait pas pour nous de
construire une nouvelle école
complètement différente et de balayer
radicalement l'éducation d'aujourd'hui
de nos établissements non notre école a
des valeurs allaient structurantes lé
type le monde et elle joue un rôle
social important dans notre société et
les enseignants y apporte une richesse
pédagogique extraordinaire
mais l'école ne peut plus rester un lieu
fermé où les enseignants transmettre des
savoirs et des connaissances aux élèves
dans un cadre qui est très formel très
structuré on connaît tous les emplois du
temps de nos enfants de nos élèves ou
les courses s'enchaînent les uns après
les autres dans des semaines hyperchargé
français histoire géographie anglais svt
technologies sciences physiques etc
notre école doit évoluer elle doit se
transformer petit à petit et elle doit
se reconnecter à cette société en
constante évolution
notre vision est de changer notre
rapport à l'espace
changer la relation que nous avons avec
ce lieu que représente l'école dans
l'esprit de chacun et voir
l'établissement scolaire comme un
écosystème ouvert sur la société
compléter la pédagogie formelle qui
reste utile et nécessaire par une
pédagogie plus informelle une pédagogie
qui facilitera l'innovation la
créativité la prise de risque
l'entrepreneuriat
c'est en fait construire une école
hybrides alors hybride je vous rassure
ça veut pas dire simplement ajouter du
numérique ou simplement présentiel
existentielle on connaît ça très bien
mais hybride dans le sens improbable
original une école et brice est une
école où se mélangent les générations
les talents les intérêts les projets les
apprentissages
et c'est ainsi qu'est né le concept du
cube en faire un tiers lieu pédagogique
et éducatif
alors c'est quoi un tir lieu c'est un
troisième lieu qui favorise les échanges
les interactions les projets les
croisements entre deux autres lieux deux
autres monde pour nous celui de
l'éducation et celui des entreprises
associations start partisans alors il
existe de nombreux types de tenir lieu
de nombreux formats de tient lieu avec
presque autant de définitions
différentes deux tiers lieux on pourrait
en prendre quelques exemples en faire
une synthèse mais c'est inutile
un tiers lieux ne se définit pas par ce
qu'il est il se définit par ce que l'on
en fait un tiers lieux ne se crée pas il
se révèle le cube s'est révélé pour nous
comme une évidente évolution de
l'éducation dans ce futur désirable
les acteurs du cube sont donc élèves
étudiants enseignants parents et
entreprises associations start partisans
ville collectivités région artistes
chercheurs
mais
pour faire tenir lieu
il faut passer de ce collectif au commun
faire communauté
ce que nous avons tous en commun dans le
cube
c'est l'éducation l'éducation est une
relation et elle nous apprend la
relation
nous souhaitons construire et évoluer
vers une communautés apprenantes
nous avons tous tous une responsabilité
éducative dans cette société nous sommes
où seront tous
éducateur ou éduquer à différents
moments de notre vie
on entend beaucoup parler de la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
la rse le cube lui incarne et permet de
mettre en avant de mettre en action la
responsabilité éducative il permet à
chacun et collectivement de se saisir de
son pouvoir d'agir dans cette société
après cinq années de réflexion d'analysé
de réunion d' écoute le cube a ouvert
ses portes le 1er septembre 2020 vous
comprenez mieux par ces photos pourquoi
nous l'avons appelé le cube c'est
simplement la forme du bâtiment
tous les codes scolaire ils y ont été
supprimés plus de sonneries par exemple
qui indique la fin d'un cours ou le
début d'un autre ou qui indique même à
quel moment il faut faire une pause
pas de mobilier scolaire pas de bureau
de profs mais pour que les entreprises
associations start partisans ville etc
s'y invitent ils travaillent et
participe donc à l'évolution de cette
commune prenantes il faut que les
espaces soient attractifs
modulable flexible innovants et surtout
que des services soient proposés sur les
quatre niveaux de 1200 m² chacun alors
rapidement les différents espaces au
niveau -1 nous avons des espaces cinéma
audiovisuel avec au coeur une régie un
studio fonds vers une salle de
projection une salle de montage et une
salle de préparation on peut il vivre
des événements en présentiel ou
existentielle et enregistrer ou diffuser
des émissions en direct et réaliser des
émissions des podcasts ou et radios etc
au niveau zéro c'est l'accueil et le fab
lab le laboratoire de fabrication
on rentre par l'espace accueil
exposition réception et ensuite le fab
lab nous offre un atelier fabrication
bois un atelier fabrication métal une
arène robotique et un espace maquettage
et prototypage rapide avec imprimante 3d
scanner 3d découpe laser ce fablab
permet la rencontre
entre l'inde et travail artisanal
emmanuel des plus anciens celui du bois
et des équipements de très haute
technologie
au niveau 1 c'est l'expérience
utilisateur qui est mise en avant
tous les espaces ont été réfléchies pour
mieux comprendre analyser observer et
faire évoluer l'expérience utilisateur
dans différents domaines c'est également
sur sept étages que l'on retrouve le
centre de relation client et l' espace
de coworking pour que chacun puisse s'y
installer sur la durée souhaitée il
travaillait profiter des espaces du cube
et donc participer à l'évolution de
cette communauté prenantes
au niveau 2 c'est le développement
durable qui est source d'apprentissage
de projets et d'événements c'est
également les d'âge le plus ouvert ce
qui nous permet d'y organiser des grands
événements sipa caton
au delà de tous ces apprentissages ses
services ces projets qui font le
quotidien du cube
le cube se veut aussi être un lieu
de réflexion un lieu d'expérimentation
un laboratoire pour notre société et
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons
souhaité organiser en mai et juin 2021
notre première édition du cube à et ses
deux mois pour prendre le temps
d'analyser de comprendre un thème
sociétal qui interpelle les différents
acteurs du cube éducation entreprises
associations et ce premier thème choisi
a été comment reconnaître et valoriser
les talents les compétences tout au long
de la vie
proposé 1 concept à proximité d'un
établissement scolaire
sans qu'il y ait eu auparavant une
préparation une acculturation une
mutation des pratiques pédagogiques des
enseignants
sera très compliqué c'est pourquoi
depuis cinq ans des enseignants se
prépare à accueillir le cube cinq ans
pour que le cube soit une évidence
plutôt qu'ils se demandent comment
l'utiliser à son ouverture c'est
l'équivalent de 5 ans d'édition du
printemps de l'innovation pédagogique
d'une semaine de l'avenir et de nombreux
autres rendez vous pédagogique qui ont
lieu au sein de l'établissement
ce qui rend le cube unique
c'est d'abord ce concept de tiers lieu
pédagogique et éducatif à proximité d'un
établissement scolaire
c'est ensuite la concentration dans un
même et unique bâtiment de tels espaces
de tels services de tels équipements
mais c'est ce qui permet de créer ces
rencontres improbables et original
et c'est surtout la reconnaissance et la
valorisation des compétences informel
qui y sont développées nous attribuons
des open badge qui viennent en
complément des diplômes et qui permet à
chacun de rentrer dans une dynamique de
développement personnel et professionnel
tout au long de la vie
dans son livre au crépuscule des lieux
pierre georget ni nous annonce notre
changement de relation au lieu dans un
contexte de transition fulgurante celui
que nous vivons il annonce la naissance
de lieux à fort potentiel de création et
de sens
des lieux catalyseur tels que le cube
dans le domaine de l'éducation mais
peut-être à venir d'autres lieux dans
d'autres domaines
proposer une vision telle que celle du
cube la mettre en oeuvre c'est s'exposer
c'est prendre des risques
mais l'essentiel n'est pas la vision
sait c'est qu'elle nous fait faire au
quotidien 'aujourd'hui
l'origine de la vision est également
bien moins importante que la manière
dont elle se diffuse j'espère que de
nombreux autres tiers lieu pédagogique
éducatif verront le jour ailleurs en
france
mais j'espère surtout ce soir vous avoir
donné envie de retourner sur les bancs
de l'école
vous avoir donné envie de participer à
l'évolution de cette communauté un
prenantes vous avoir donné envie de vous
saisir de votre pouvoir d'agir dans
cette société
et si nous avions tous ensemble cette
idée folle de réinventer l'école merci
[Applaudissements]